[Music]
i know we talk about this a lot on the
show but lately it's really struck me
how old i've been feeling there are
certain physiological realities you
laughing physiological
but like you know your body's slowing
down things changing whatever i don't
even mean that i have an older person's
mindset i come to complete stops at stop
signs now if people blow through them i
get irate littering shake your fist with
them i kind of do
damn i mean i don't say you damn kids
but i say a version of that
i feel so out of touch with some of the
pop culture trends like the song [ __ ]
the cardi b song or as you call her
cardib
i discovered what it meant what the
acronym wap stands for and i'm not gonna
say it but uh if you don't know you
people know people know i think people
know at this point i i came to know very
late and i was outraged the way
our parents would be i remember hearing
adults react that way to pop culture
songs when we were kids like um
you know they couldn't play like two
life crew or something like that they
were outrageous it's outrageous it's
outrageous second year outrage and uh
but i'm old too so what do i know
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
this is the two old guys doing a show
called life is short i'm your host
justin long could be a dream
[Music]
with me as always is my fellow aging
co-host and brother aging not asian yeah
no no i should have made that clear
we're all aging yeah we are and yeah [ __ ]
is something that i'm outraged by too
not not that i think it's i'm not sure
i'm not so outraged that i think like
it shouldn't exist and but there's part
of me that thinks kids kids shouldn't be
i know uh repeating it well you know we
were talking to church lady we were i
know i know it's like from it's satan's
responsible uh we were talking to our
friend jerry o'connell a frequent guest
friend of the show friend of the show
and jerry posted something that really
made me laugh and i was commiserating
with him about uh which is that his kids
were the one his kids introduced him get
revealed what that meant what that
acronym meant and he imagined like i
can't commiserate with that obviously i
don't have kids but like imagine
that feeling imagine how old he must
have felt well jerry is i would say
and he's kind of a heavy like hipper
than us oh yeah and he's more in touch
with yeah he's much going on culturally
much more certainly in pop culture i
know than we are oh yeah um that's an
understatement in fact he posted yeah
he's the wendy will he's very much in
touch
with popular culture and he was
outraged he was outraged
mom's gonna listen to this episode well
she you know i think i told her what it
meant really and she was like no i mean
she wasn't as outraged as i thought
she'd be maybe she doesn't have the
bandwidth to be more outraged because
she's so often outraged by pop culture
things um but like when we were kids uh
and and here's a rebuttal to what a
rebuttal to why it shouldn't be maybe so
outrageous um this particular song when
we were kids we had opp naughty by
nature yeah you know you know him
opp yeah you know me and that stands for
i don't know i remember this song but i
don't i don't think i remember it stands
for other people's
pelicans yeah pelicans were and
whereas this is wet ass pelicans oh yeah
so they used the word pelicans
they had already that was a mainstrea i
would say mainstream song naughty by
nature they and they were
in fact naughty by nature but it strikes
me that the kids who are into [ __ ] right
now yeah not the actual thing but the
song and we should clarify it's not the
acronym the offensive italian slur right
i might be wrong but it strikes me that
the kids who are into that song now are
you younger
than the kids who are into opp when we
were kids or am i wrong well well you
might be wrong because we were a little
out of touch with that even because we
weren't into
we weren't into like the cool i remember
cool kids being like cool kids like high
school middle school
older kids not like children not like
not like jerry's kids nine year olds i
know maybe you're right yeah being and
also opp
it was masked a little bit better it
wasn't it was more veiled it wasn't like
it wasn't a song all about clearly wet
ass pelicans well why are we talking
about feeling old and being good
question
are i have a guess go for it um our
guest today is
the very funny one of my favorite
comedians of all time nick kroll you did
that backwards i did our guest today
played i i kind of agree at this point
uh a very funny old person in the show
oh hello oh so i can say well why are we
talking about old people right christian
why are we talking about old people
today and then misha i have to just mix
it up no i think we should keep it like
this you do this yeah or is it real this
is real kids do like the like real stuff
mm-hmm yeah well this is um intro
realness
it's so raw not edited that intro uh i
should be better at this it's amazing
how many shows have we done 70 something
you're really not good at this and
nicholas i mean you're good at a lot of
aspects of the podcast you're just not
getting this part but i really value
nick's opinion of me too so uh you know
well hopefully he doesn't listen uh
hopefully he does though and so nick
kroll hopefully he's charmed by oh i'm
getting this right
the hilarious nick crawl very funny
stand-up comedian uh like we just said
he was in the show oh hello which was on
broadway and was on netflix yeah that's
where i saw it um
uh he's also
the star and creator of kroll show and
he's he's done he's been popping up over
the years and really funny he's he's a
scene stealer and a lot of like judd
apatow movies a lot of great comedies um
nick has always been
uh just one of the funniest people
uh in the last 10 15 years but now he
has his own animated show well he has
for a couple years called big mouth
which i'm really into can't recommend it
enough uh i'm sure a lot of you
listening
watch it but um
it's just incredible also from a a vocal
standpoint i mean the show's very funny
and all that and it's really well really
insightful about a time uh in in life
that is kind of hard to talk about so
they're
very smart and deft about how they
address these
like really important
um issues for kids i think it's like
we've talked about that it's a really
positive show for kids let's just hear
it why am i talking about us talking
about it when we could just hear us
talking about let's hear it
uh okay uh without further ado
with uh here's my my talk with my
ketchup with my friend and the very very
funny without further ado i do right not
a jew what did i say i said idea again i
don't know it's a do it's a dude i don't
know why that still sounds like much ado
about nothing i know that's right
without that's right we've been over
this i know the shorties uh we can't
have we can't write a short scan about
this okay so without further ado
here is my catch-up with a great dude
very funny very clever thanks oh thanks
he's gonna love that uh and also a very
smart introspective guy uh let's hear it
though okay i know i'm just introducing
who knows if he's smart and
introspective i'm just saying what i
think of him and so then you can make
your own judgments oh okay
now right now go nick cross your
judgment okay
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
oh
hey hello hello
where are you nick i'm in my house in
los angeles yeah where are you i moved
to the burbs really i'm in connecticut
i'm like five minutes from uh where i
grew up in this town connecticut what
town are you from again uh fairfield
connecticut yeah yeah yeah i mean i grew
up in westchester so i know the that's
right and rye yeah yeah so are you did
you get a house near where you grew up
yeah it was right before the quarantine
uh which and then prove to be lucky
because you know my parents who are very
i don't know how your parents are uh
are your parents stubborn
like everyone's are about going out and
stuff i i had been running errands for
them uh but they were insisting on going
out yeah my parents weren't terrible
they
they were a little stubborn at first and
then
they i think got the gravity of it and
now i think they realize especially my
dad is like psyched not to leave the
house but i think that i really the
beginning of the pandemic felt like
everybody being so angry with their
parents that they were not responsible
inside of this thing
and then like also now being like oh
everybody's parents were like i don't
want to think of myself as old yeah and
needing to take care of but is your dad
why does he he's just like a homebody he
just like likes being i think he's just
like oh i can do all my meetings on zoom
and i don't have to go into the city to
an office i can like be with my family
and you know i think he's just like
happy to hang i don't know it's it's
it's really interesting i i thought he
and i are sort of similar where i'm like
well the reality is i can't do x y and z
so why be
bummed that i can't do it what is it
like in ellie now because i was supposed
to go out there this week is it just
awesome
dude it's awesome it's um
it looks beautiful the weather is
perfect um skies have never been clearer
the dust particles are so big that you
can feel them in your throat as you
breathe in god
i have been on the east coast with my
staying largely with my parents um oh
really during the lockdown yeah we we
went for like five weeks we flew and
stayed for a long time on the east coast
and
got back just in time to catch the fires
we got back and it's like oh so it's now
double covered you can't go see people
and now they've taken away outdoor
outdoor visiting
yeah it's just there's no outdoors
spending time anywhere
no hiking yeah anything that makes
living in la a joy so you had been with
your parents and before the lockdown or
you had you you went out there for just
to be with them i went with my uh with
my girlfriend lily we went and stayed we
flew at the beginning of august and
stayed through labor day um and
just figured it was
it was you know we we just were like
let's just do it and got back and and it
was great it was really wonderful i mean
one new york was new york's vibe is we
left la just as the numbers were spiking
and
feeling like oh we're we're now getting
hit with this as and got to new york
just as new york was like oh
like we acted responsibly for a long
time and honestly also was like oh right
new york is a public life so like you
could go to brooklyn and people are
walking around and everyone's like
wearing masks and
and there's public life to be led there
you know and you feel a sense of
community versus l.a where truth is like
la's been practicing social distancing
for like 50 years so like
everyone's like in their home and so
isolated anyway yeah and and even more
so now and and there isn't the sense of
public life like as weird as the grove
is like it's one of the few places in
l.a to like walk around when i think
about social things in l.a the few
things like you mentioned the grove any
sort of farmers market but i think about
like to go to those concerts the
hollywood bowl and and
outdoor you know griffith park uh
or the cemetery screening stuff like
that
and i don't know if they're i honestly
don't they might be happening that was
very sweet of you you invited me to the
hollywood bowl to see uh what was that
show it was the we said jurassic park
jurassic park yeah it was really fun
yeah
the john williams score right it was the
yeah oh god was that great i remember
watching that with you and being like
this whole thing is newman's fault
it's all newman's fault that's
[ __ ] this yeah newman has screwed up
the whole thing
yes one big like newman no man
yeah uh and then you get to i i think
you were doing a show that night you
were sweet to come because i know you
were busy um it was my pleasure you had
mentioned your girlfriend at the time
and
you just mentioned you she came back
with you to your parents is it is it i
don't know how to say this is
yeah um
i have to say like you know the
quarantine is such a
has been i think such a make or break
for so many uh people and couples and we
went into it together and and have come
out you know stronger and you and lilly
yeah and um
that is a you know and i definitely
think like either the quarantine made
couples like realize like oh they're
supposed to be together forever or that
this is over you know yeah at what point
did that start to really gel during the
corner like would you go into the
quarantine knowing that it was going to
be a length of time you were going to be
together did you go in nervous at all
were you thinking or was she was it like
oh [ __ ] this could be this is gonna be
intense i don't know i i mean i think it
was like at least for uh me i i don't
know we knew how long it was gonna be it
felt like all right it's mid-march
uh i mean we closed our writer's room on
march 11th or we closed it you know in
the physical sense we went right into
zoom on march 12th how much more of the
season did you have to do sorry we had
we were halfway through the season so we
really wrote broke
and wrote and voiced the second half of
season five
uh season five yeah yeah we're a year
ahead of wherever the show is
oh my god wow in the public so
we started march 12th on zoom
and our last table read was like june
9th or 10th it was supposed to be the
week before but all the
george floyd protests and
the true reckoning of our country's
deep level the reckoning happened that
weekend yeah so that um so we it got
delayed a week but basically that was
the bookend for the quarantine and the
second half of our writing and voicing
do you think in addition to like i mean
you had mentioned that this this has
been like a make or break time for
couples do you think in addition to just
being together um for so long just being
like insulated for so long do you think
uh the fact that all of the as you
mentioned these this cultural reckoning
is happening and we're we're at the
crossroads of like a really
powerful
movement do you think that is
uh
illuminating whether or not people are
supposed to how solid relationships are
i mean have you noticed in your own that
like oh when i compare it to
everything that's happening this is
somebody that i want to kind of be
together with i want to like
see see it out with yeah i think it's
like you're in the [ __ ] you know what i
mean so like yeah if you can come
through it and feel like you've got a
partner in this time of where people's
work is going away or people are getting
slammed with work and people are
losing their minds in the virtual spaces
of our lives or
need extra support or love or
somebody you can just laugh with i mean
like yeah you can just get through that
and
maintain a buoyancy with somebody yeah
just like oh you don't want to like read
the news and freak out about this all
day either great like we're a good fit
oh you want to learn to cook like we
just
i didn't make a single loaf of bread but
i definitely like paid for the new york
times uh cooking app and have used it
you were the youngest
i'll ask you in the context of big mouth
how much of that show is
autobiographical like how much of it is
you how much of it is john's family uh
none of it's john's family john oh
andrew gold yeah andrew goldberg who was
yeah
who i co-created the show with him and
and mark levin and jen flackett and
right andrew and i have known each other
since
first grade and we became like best
friends you know in middle school and
and state have stayed very close
throughout our lives
and many of the early story lines came
from our lives like his i love his not
growing his growing like the facial hair
and his parents so his parents really
waxed it his parents really did wax his
upper lip and he couldn't grow he
couldn't grow any a mustache for years
he'd grow full beard like the one i have
now he could grow in like seventh grade
oh my god
or the little spot below his nose from
the relaxing which we called his reverse
hitler yeah
and i and i was definitely i was the
youngest i was a super late bloomer i
didn't get pubes until high school
all that kind of stuff too that's why
that character i really relate to nick
really uh yeah i was
maybe a senior maybe a junior late
junior year is that what you i mean i
think i had some pubes before that i
started growing
like sophomore year i started growing
but when i got to high school i was like
five feet tall you know i don't know
me too i
410
410 i weighed 89 pounds yeah cause i my
parents finally let me i almost said
audition for the football team my
parents finally let me try out for
football i was literally yeah 89 pounds
holy [ __ ] four foot ten yeah um
i'm a little behind in big mouth but uh
oh god it's brilliant i just saw the um
the scene where jack with the two he has
two pews for a while and jack mcpray and
craig robinson yeah just such great
casting um
spoiler alert craig's pube the people
that craig voices is dying it's just
it's so well done it's so yeah uh you
know there's a lot of crude stuff
obviously it's so funny and it's also
really like touching and i'm
it's reminding me of this time in life
that is so
[ __ ] weird that it can only really be
animated that's why the whole concept is
brilliant but it's done so thank you and
it's bringing up all these memories
we're like i remember when like you
couldn't spare a pube yeah no i i mean i
had i remember counting my pubes like i
remember at the end of eighth grade i
got my first like pube or two and but
you know i i still wasn't like in
puberty really yeah and i was just and
you know looking back once we started
working on the show i realized like
andrew realized like i was like oh i
felt so
underdeveloped and i felt so embarrassed
about that i felt embarrassed that i
like had it like still had a boy penis
and not a you know it wasn't hairy it
wasn't growing like everybody else's and
then andrew was like oh i felt like i
was ridden with acne and i had no
control over my body and i felt
completely
terrible inside of it and you know you
realize like oh everybody no matter
where you are or how it falls is kind of
miserable inside of this process and
that's been very cathartic inside the
show and for women too sorry to
interrupt but
i was i'm watching the episode where the
girl with the develop boobs you're
compassionate to her point of view and
um i probably shouldn't say this but my
brother's girlfriend was
i think in that position maggie was in
that position and she was like we were
like come on it must be must have been
great the attention and like having
boobs and like and she was like
absolutely and it's so alienating and um
so yeah to your point it's just i think
just weird for everyone definitely the
girl with the big boobs who's like
sexualized before she's ready or having
attention that she doesn't necessarily
want and you know we i think we joke in
the show it's like the new girl she's
like she's not new she's been at the
school the whole time you just never and
well part of her is new yeah so it
definitely we we try to you know we try
to tackle it from all the different
angles it started with us two but then
as we've built the show and you'll see
as you continue watching it really
became an opportunity to explore all of
these different stories um you know
there's jay and mandzukic plays jay and
that is he he's a magician and he has
but he also
you know [ __ ] his pillows and that
that's you know those are those are
pulled from a couple of different
friends of ours from that age who you
know a couple different people um
there's definitely the pillows come to
life i'm just telling people this they
come to life the pillows become
characters uh some of the greatest
characters are these the figments of
your imagination you're like there's an
embodiment of your horniness that
do you voice both of those do you do
maurice and yes and rick jesus yeah i do
yeah
i i was watching an episode of conan and
he said he called you the mel the mel
blanc of our time it was just like you
guys were joking about what a like
you know dated reference that isn't like
there were crickets but i i know what a
um and what a compliment that is and and
like i think it's true i think it
applies to you like
they're also so different each of these
characters so i i um it's so great and i
i definitely want to go through some of
them but um where did that come from
where did that idea to kind of embody
those the hormone monster that you're
more mori maurice is is
that was sort of another example of
andrew was talking to mark and jen and
he was like you know andrew should have
this kind of like a hormone monster to
like you know that and and they were
like well not a kind of it should be a
hormone monster and then they they
called me and they're like we were
thinking andrew should have a hormone
monster and i immediately was just like
touch yourself andrew you know and it
was
and it was it just wasn't me does that
hurt to do it does a little bit it more
than anything it hurts that people think
uh it's will arnett or that i'm doing a
will or net impression uh you know it's
i'm sorry to add to the hurt but it um
this is a testament to your talent i i
was trying to put my finger on who it
was because i thought i thought it might
be you then i thought well who else
would it be uh yeah i mean
it was so funny people were like
you know is it will or not would you are
you doing a will or not impression i was
like i mean you know we came on the air
and bojack was already there and and and
i have a tremendous amount of respect
for will as a
in general but especially i mean his
voice work is amazing i would never
purposefully do a right anything it just
was like it was a voice that i had done
on on kroll show um this character nash
ricky who was like a aging kind of uh
glam rock metal guy
uh it was a small
one-off character that i built uh he was
i had an ocd issue and and uh uh in
recovery and um and so i had done that
voice for that and so then i was like oh
that and then i didn't even think about
it it came out that way and and rick who
is coach steve's hormone monster slash
nick's hormone monster
yeah it's kind of you swallow how do you
do it
it's it's like uh it's tightening the
i don't even know how to that's funny we
had uh howie mandel was on he was
talking about doing gizmo yeah and she's
like he does this
yeah it was bobby's world bobby's world
was a big influence on andrew and i
growing up it was really more than even
the i mean it was the show but there was
a moment where he did a um
oh he was gizmo
yeah yeah bobby is the same voice but
it's thought um he was gizmo yeah oh
yeah and i forget how he i should
remember this he described how he did it
it was like a thing that he did uh in
his act i think
he but similar to how you're describing
shutting you it's like if your throat is
a like
sphincter like you're just like
tightening the sphincter
that's so funny of course he's gizmo but
there was a i remember growing up andrew
and i would watch there was a there
might have just been an ad for it but
it was bobby's world and it was like
bobby the philosopher
and then he would say like kids should
have credit cards
and so
that oh yeah i kind of i was weirdly so
that always stuck with andrew and i but
then
steve has this broken down hormone
monster like he's an adult he shouldn't
have one anymore but he's got one it's
just like no it's just been around for
two years that's right because
he's like has arrested development he's
still a child you know that episode's
amazing when you learn that steve has
not
that has not uh had sex with a woman i
didn't know that you even could outside
of making a baby yeah know you could
have sex with lady and he didn't know
you could make didn't know you could
make thick into warm you know it's as is
how he describes it making thinking
that's right and he says something about
his the way he describes his wet dreams
is yeah i make
sheet sneezes
yeah yeah you know i have a sheet sneeze
uh yeah where does that
they all the other thing is they sound
so specific uh which is why people maybe
think it is actually will or not but
where where does that where does coach
steve come coach steve was another kind
of character i did on kroll show named
ref jeff who always just wanted to kind
of hang he always just like wanted to
hang out and the first video was it's
like a mic'd on the court and it's like
a ref who just wants to hang out with
the players which we sort of discovered
on the day we didn't know we just knew
we we wanted him to be a ref with a big
butt like and now yeah you're always
yeah you're always backing guys out
there always coming behind you we just
thought of a guy who was like a
gym coach who was really sweet who
wanted to hang out with the kids but not
in a creepy way
right right and that's interesting and
then we realized he was super dumb and
then it was fun doing the math
it's fun to do the math of a
of a dumb guy like that like what
his like
sometimes it gets too complicated but
like what is the the boiled down essence
of something
that how he would describe it so like
having sex with a woman he would say is
making thicken the warm
because like that is the essence of uh
right just reduce it yeah yes yeah it's
weird it's done with and they're kids
so you're it's a tricky combination it's
a tricky territory to play in and
sometimes you reference it like at the
end of one episode i think you even say
like well this would be like weird and
borderline child porn if it weren't
animated like wink
and yeah with steve i'm thinking of like
the episode with the with the girl with
the boobs and everyone's being
interviewed about her boobs and he's he
starts talking about he's like oh it's
the best and you realize he's talking
about his
whistle yeah yeah he's in love with his
wife yeah no it's it's a very fun
character to write for you it's a very
oh he's so fun to write for and it's uh
it's a weird time right now as well
because i definitely
um
seem to get like online by the people
who don't like me very much uh tend to
like to call me a pedophile because of
this animated show yeah because of the
show because we're talking very frankly
about sexuality and and kid sexuality
and there are moments where you see
nudity of some sort or other um
in our opinion it's like no like you see
a
you know some
portion of a a child
you know it's an one it's a cartoon
voiced by adults but also
it's not as just seeing something new
doesn't mean it's a sexual thing like
there's no yeah there's no sexuality
attached to it but that's a hard
distinction for people to make
especially people who are very excited
to call people pedophiles you know yeah
i mean i've been uh i've noticed on i
started doing instagram really for this
but um occasionally i'll post about a uh
this
the thing that you did that you were so
kind to do they were the home in
nicaragua that you did a show for very
kindly um yeah i'll even post about that
and occasionally a lot of people say
accuse me of being a pedophile
just connected to that um i think that's
the thing that's getting thrown around
now by a lot of um people who don't
trust hollywood and whatever i think
that's politically motivated it's a bit
of a minefield and but i think our goal
is is very anti-pedophile
no it's really like it's really gonna
talk frankly about
human development and sexuality and that
kids
are especially i mean like anybody who
says like a 13 year old 14 year old
who's entered puberty is not having
sexual feelings is not really
properly
addressing what's happening in the world
and like you know the p a lot of people
ask me all the time like what age is it
appropriate to show my kid and what da
da nice i'm like look i don't know
every parent has a different
relationship with their kid and what
andrew has said is like when my kids are
the age of the kids on the show then
they can watch the show and and that's
sort of what i've said in general but
also it's like feel free to not show the
kids the show but don't for a second
think that your kids don't have access
to
content on the internet that is much
less uh responsible in the messaging
that it's putting out in animated form
yeah in this kind of heightened
fantastical way you guys are telling
these really like
i i not to sound too pretentious but i
think they're really important stories
for kids going through puberty to be
watching i i
if i had kids i would uh yeah you'd let
them watch it
at some point it's also yeah at some
point yeah once they've um
the nicest thing that i've gotten is
like when season one came out i was
going to my nephew's bar mitzvah so it
was like kids who were squarely in that
age and he and his friends were watching
the show and telling us about what they
liked about telling me what they liked
about it and then i went to like the
luncheon and a bunch of his the kids
parents were there who are you know all
my like my brother's age and
obviously closer to my generation than
anything else and you know originally we
wrote the show thinking it would be for
people like us to watch i didn't know
that kids would really watch the show we
were trying to be responsible about it
but like we didn't know
and talking to parents it was like this
gave us some vocabulary and platforms to
start to have these conversations or to
be like good you guys are telling about
it we don't have to
yeah right you know so it's almost like
it lets the parents off the hook in a
way yeah uh we try to we try to be very
mindful of like what messages are being
put out there you know while we're not
trying to like be preachy and messaging
we are aware of the what could be
gleaned from these episodes and yet it
doesn't lose any of its edge it's not at
all like sanitized um it's just it's
weird yeah it's a fine line to walk now
that now that i think about it to be
responsible but also funny and edgy yeah
we have this year this coming season
season four which comes out october 16th
it's season four and we
what i will say is while we're doing an
animated it seems that is the easiest
way to talk about it i don't know if
you've seen pen 15 on hulu no but people
keep recommending it i guess
they're that is a similar it's to call
it live action big mouth is does
it a disservice because it's its own
thing entirely but
anna and maya are the stars that they
wrote and created it and they play
they're they're adult women playing 13
year old girls and so it allows them to
be 13 but it also we know that they're
adults so like you can sort of watch
them do things and it's not creepy it's
not creepy it gives them license to
explore it in a more way in a stream and
we actually have them
on big mouth they're they're playing
the the kids on the show on big mouth
are now entering eighth grade um because
we're moving them forward in time and
we have anna and maya playing uh seventh
graders andrew and nick are like
now in eighth grade going after the
seventh grade girls and and it's funny
and they have their own kind of they
think they're in their own show the
girls do
um but we thought it was a funny little
like
yeah that's cool puberty show crossover
um and they're awesome and they're so
funny and great but it's you know there
are more shows now
sex education on on on netflix also is
their high school kids it's very frank
um but there's more and more shows that
are kind of really dealing with stuff in
a way that um
is
you know
pushing the envelope but also really
trying to address like what is it like
to be
going through puberty to be
having frank discussions about sexuality
and and i think there's really utility
to that like i think to ignore it as to
one
like it's unhealthy physically and
mentally and true it's such a fruitful
area to i know tell stories because it's
this is so high everything feels so you
know and for for everyone i think about
the people who would object to the show
or whoever was saying that stuff online
i i know for a fact i just know that
they struggled in during that time like
that's that's just an odd time for
everyone and and it's you do it in such
an honest way in a way that it's the
only way to do it um
i i the last one i saw so it's in my
head but i just keep thinking of that
the boob episode where
you know kids that age talk about seeing
boo and
talk about seeing boobs in a way that
like explorers will talk about you know
finding uh huh
you know some great uh court the sea of
cortez or something where they like
describe it in this
and look i of course i remember that
time that that was yeah i think
everybody goes through that it's part of
life yeah for me i think i was again i
was so small but i could kind of talk to
girls and was i had older sisters so i
was comfortable in that realm
i definitely was like trying to find the
girl with the big boobs so i could like
hook up with her and touch them both
because it
you know felt good but also because i
wanted that validation i wanted to be
like i touched the big boobs like i
might be small but i'm not inadequate or
whatever you know it was definitely like
you know exploring
and again the stuff that like we are
dealing with that in that those
formative found foundational years are
things that we spend the rest of our
lives then dealing with life could be a
dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wandery plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
so having older sisters because i don't
know what that's like you it was it just
you were around older girls so you were
more comfortable around them just
talking i think so i had two older
sisters um who were awesome um big
sisters to me and and taught me how to
talk to girls and taught me like how to
listen to girls and so like so and i was
just comfortable around girls because of
that so when i actually was like dealing
with girls my own age i wasn't like
complete they weren't this foreign
object and they also you know
and also my sisters had to like teach me
to be like they are human beings with
feelings and
um need to be treated as such in a way
that i think boys at that age don't
always do well also just just having
them i'm just knowing that you had this
living example of that in your home you
had older sisters that's got to help you
yeah totally i mean it took a while it's
not like i was for i mean beyond not
perfect as it
but it definitely helped
humanize the opposite sex in a way that
was very illuminating were you into
performing as a kid were you very
outgoing very funny uh what type of kid
were you i was a bit of a ham and a
performer andrew and i actually would do
like in at our out at our middle school
but also we went to the same summer camp
and and this season of big mouth season
four
the first three episodes take place at
summer camp it was because andrew and i
went to camp and had story fun stories
to tell there but like so we would do
like uh campfire skits and stuff like
that and we would host talent shows that
are at our middle school and i was
definitely a little performer i think a
lot of that was being the youngest and
were you doing impressions
impressions of teachers and stuff
wayne's world we were hosting like yeah
you know purim talent show at our school
as like wayne and guard
and i you know you and i are the same
similar ages and like you know wayne's
world was huge huge yeah in fact i just
found out i'm three years three days
older than you really
yeah june 2nd wow
june 2nd 1978. wow we're like wow we are
lined up age-wise when i think i just
heard jack on your jack mcbride um
every year jack mcprayer calls me on my
birthday yeah jack i feel like jack
mcbrayer who i think everybody knows you
know to some extent from 30 rock and and
has done so many other things is you
know the sweetest guy in the world and
also very funny and mean when he wants
to be but um very and very funny and
mean on the show i love his arc as the
pube on the show great um he's so great
but he calls it he calls people on their
birthday he remembers everybody's
birthday he calls everybody if he didn't
i'd be hurt you know and now i'm
expecting it i'm still there's still a
part of me that's like so sweetly
surprised and he's always like of course
i did yeah your parents were strict now
i'm thinking about the show um how
similar were they to like andrew on the
show andrew's parents are quite strange
andrew's so on the show andrew's father
is the closest
to richard
richard amazing the king
we did a zoom at the beginning we did a
live table read at the beginning of the
quarantine to raise money for feeding
america and richard
did it because he he's incredibly
generous with his time and talents and
he was doing he
showed up on the zoom this is a public
very public zoom eating an ear of corn
he was eating an ear of corn on video
what what's the matter yeah how did you
do it when you do the impression of him
like i'm trying to think about andrew
and you know
what he taught i i wish i could do it
it's you do it it's i i what's
yeah it's pretty good that's pretty good
it's he's just gone
he's got the best so he's the closest
like andrew's kid saw the drawing for
uh marty glauberman on the show and they
saw the initial design for it and they
go oh it's grandpa like they saw it
immediately he's the closest he's kind
of the closest one to one the rest of
the you know my parents
i come from a very loving family so the
element of like there's like a lot of
love maybe too much love maybe too much
is i think of is like where my dad is
completely different than elliot who's
voiced by fred armisen but there's a
similarity now my dad there's a lot of
toasts in my family like a lot of a lot
of toasting a lot of expressions of love
it's
i'm
incredibly lucky that but
my dad does not have a tiny little uh
penis and um
and uh well that's good to know that
okay we can break that that's the
breaking news um like elliot um he's and
he's not he's a very different guy but
but
but the similarity is there's a ton of
love from him
and my mom
is
similar in certain regards to to the mom
on the show and that again it's very
frank discussions about sexuality and
sexual
she was very clear with me early on
about you haven't hit puberty your
friends have their nipples are going to
be
swollen and their eyebrows are growing
in and stuff like that that was no
kidding she said that yeah she was
trying to demystify all of it yeah and
wow meant with love and and to to try to
educate but you know when i was a little
kid or when i was young i it's like you
can give a kid information but it
doesn't mean the kid's going to do
something healthy with it and my
siblings i have two sisters we combined
into one sister and my brother
uh jeremy who's now like an incredibly
loving hard-working decent father and
husband
uh for
um when he was in high school he was a
bit of like a scary menace like he he
had that you know that older brother
who's like quiet and it's like judd on
the show my brother was some version
therein
um huh but well now he's married to he
has four kids all three of my siblings
have four kids i have twelve oh my god
and so do you guys do big yeah you know
thanksgiving a lot of big family
gatherings it's a really loving
big family but you know wow as you get
older you realize like every family has
[ __ ] you know and so sure sure um the
show you get to explore that how cool
you get yeah and go back and like all
the characters on the show it's like it
begins with a seed of some truth and
then you create like your own the
character sort of begin to tell you what
they want you to do and and it moves
away from
it takes on a whole reality but you're
on a life of its own uh
nick was
with the impetus for you've mentioned a
lot of like the kroll show characters
that you did were there some characters
that you
saw drawn out i mean this is probably a
dumb question but you'd see the
animation you'd say oh that's
that's this i have a voice for that how
would you choose the voices for some of
those
very oftentimes for my voices its first
instinct um it's usually nothing's drawn
usually um
it's usually voice first and then we
draw and then
with kroll show it was definitely like i
would have sometimes a voice sometimes
though
getting i don't know if it's like this
for you as an actor but you get in the
clothes and you start to find the
character it's it sounds kind of cheesy
but it's it's
true were a lot of those uh crow show
guys were they characters that you had
been cultivating were they things that
you would come up with specifically for
the show or dude
similar to big mouth i came into it with
a bunch of
you know i had oh hello i had fabrice i
had bobby bottle service and we had rich
dicks me and john daly and then i bring
in a bunch of the voices
um some of them come in before the show
and then some of them we find
in inside the show and then even still
like anything i brought from kroll show
voices or you know seeds of characters
like lola or coach steve or
you know the voice for the hormone
monster they then
over seasons really take on a life of
their own to the point where i'll listen
to an early episode or watch an early
episode of big enough to be like boy
this voice and my mind has evolved so
much or or
you watch early cruel cruel show and
then the season three and you'll see
characters that will pop up and be like
oh that was
so different i or at least i can feel
how different they are well i was
talking to carrie brownstein about that
um how it does it starts in maybe more
superficial maybe they're the voices
that are funny and the more time you
have with these characters
the deeper you explore them and and they
take on a different they start to
develop different dimensions yeah and
yet somehow like oftentimes you ask like
how does a voice come out it it really
will just be like coach sees hormone
monster and i'll and i'll be like
oh you know like it's usually a first
instinct is the way to go and if you
if you can't crack it right away then
either for sure i'm not supposed to
voice it or
something's off with the character gil
was somebody that you had done on
and and george sink eaglin are
characters
john john and i have done
since early days of new york like i
don't know 2005 we would do a weekly
show at this place called rafifi and i'd
have been hosting it with jesse klein
she moved to la and john and i know each
other since college and i asked him to
co-host it with me and we were like
should we do this as ourselves a
stand-up and then we thought like let's
do it as these characters that we had
been talking to each other as these kind
of upper west side you know divorcee
guys and and we just love talking like
that it was like one day john said like
let's do a little cocaine and
that sort of became the like you know i
don't know if this is for you when you
when you build out a character or a
voice it's like you find that little
trigger
okay i need to say like bobby like when
i'd be switching around on crawl show
would be like oh like i knew if i would
be like oh okay very cool like that
would dig me back into totally
it's an anchor word which is what i find
so impressive about like when you're on
those talk shows and they're like do
this do that you you you i see i always
need that word and i need to kind of
readjust but you seem to be able to
essentially i was just talking to
somebody about that um
about like for example christopher
walken i said was
the crazy the word crazy yeah that's
correct you you need certain that's
something you need
it's some like
key to to
yeah like stallone what would it be
would it be great yeah i mean that's for
whatever reason my stallone is just like
hey great it's good
you know like it doesn't even matter if
it's real or not it's yeah
it's the it's again it's like i guess
it's like a trigger to to help you get
in so
fellaini said cocaine and that became
like oh okay we'll shorten the first
syllable of two syllable words
you know pid cast you guys have a pink
princess diana aka dye town
it's very funny so stupid um because
it's that because the genesis was like
you guys just making each other laugh it
was just like [ __ ] around saying
words in a funny way when you found
yourselves on broadway did you have
moments backstage where you were like
can't [ __ ] believe it [ __ ] ben
stiller's in the audience it was yeah it
it definitely was the height i had a
feeling like near the end of the run
when we we knew we had like three weeks
left and all of a sudden it was like oh
my god this is gonna end and i was like
oh this might be the top of it all like
this might be the best it ever gets
because
we're on broadway we are
a critical success we are financial
success everybody in new york is coming
to the show and wants to it was like the
show to the show
and it was so fun and i was working with
my best friend and we
and and john's wife anna was like doing
our makeup and we had the best
group of
people working on the show and it was
this cozy
it just was and i was like oh this might
be
this might be the because it was also
yeah it's just this might be the best it
gets
and like you guys had both done enough
at that point where you knew like you
know it's not like you're like 22 and
you're like cool yeah what's the next
thing you're like oh no like this might
be
this might be it um did it ever just go
off the rails because there's a lot of
audience participation was it ever just
like yeah there were a couple nights
where people started to play because we
you know we talk to the audience we
engage with them but it's different than
a comedy show where you're like it's
expected that the audience is going to
chat with you there are a couple nights
where people chatted with us we we were
pretty good at shutting it down quickly
there was one show whoopi goldberg did
the show and
she had done her breakout one woman show
in 1984
um
at the lyceum where we had done it and
oh wow there was something about her the
night she did it one we talked about the
fact that all of us felt like the
theater was a little haunted because
whoopi had done a show there and she
said there was weird [ __ ] that happened
and that night
the lights got all [ __ ] up
there was
sound issues i got off stage
the mic was still hot and i said out
loud well that sucked like
everything that could have gone wrong
wrong
oh that's like a nightmare that's like
an actor truly um that's like the it's
like the carol channing story uh
you know this story i don't know if it's
true but it's the urban
the theater urban legend like that they
tell you when you are getting acquainted
with body mics they're like um
when she was doing hello dolly like the
first run
you know she has that obviously like the
most recognizable voice and she had gone
off stage apparently left her body mic
on went to the bathroom and there were
all these like the audience like clearly
heard and it was like kind of a quiet
moment of the play
they heard like all these ambient
bathroom noises just you know splashes
whatever and then
clearly carol channing going
corn when did i have coins
and then a toilet flush
[Laughter]
i don't know oh it doesn't matter i like
her saying it by the way to herself to
herself yeah loudly that's [ __ ]
amazing in an echoey bathroom oh yeah
when did i have where are you uh i'm
trying to remember i we i was told a
story one night by
austin pendleton who
many would know as the stuttering lawyer
in my cousin
but also
incredible director and theater actor
and the original model in uh in fiddler
on the roof and they were
doing
the live like table read for friends and
family at the lyceum where we did oh
hello before they went off to like
detroit to um like workshop the show to
bring it before they brought it back to
broadway
he said they they did that like the
whole read through of it and
it was horrible it supposedly went
terribly at the run through it at the
lyceum they're running it it's going
terribly
and supposedly the newspapers were on
strike but variety and the hollywood
reporters sent their
writers to review it in detroit and it
was a snowstorm and everything was out
and they still managed to get their
story out by phone
and to let people know how terrible it
was so they're working this play over
and over in detroit it's going terribly
and jerome robbins is directing it and
they're all at the bar after a
performance and and austin sees jerry
jerome robbins at the at the end of the
bar drinking alone and austin pendleton
goes up to him he says jerry what are we
gonna do how are you doing and jerome
robbins looks at me says we're gonna fix
one thing every day
and that's what they did and they like
found i think like tradition they found
like a couple huge songs in detroit a
couple of huge numbers that then come
back and if it goes to broadway it
becomes this monster hit
but i i remember hearing uh austin
pendleton tell that story and it really
stuck with me as like as we make all the
work the work that i make the work that
you make that we all try to do whatever
it is whether it's a podcast or an
animated show or a play or
stand-up or
or you do something else in the world
it's just
all you can do is fix one thing every
day and and it helped like take off some
of the overwhelming feeling of like oh
this thing isn't working i can't and i
and there's 15 things that are wrong
it's just like that's fine just fix one
thing every day did you ever get to that
with oh hello it was when you were
workshopping that was it did it ever
feel like it's just not we're not that
oh hello was a living organism
until i'd say the last like two weeks of
the run like we you know
where we were improvising basically the
entire thing off an outline
at ucb we did like six shows at ucbl in
la
we brought by the sixth show we had like
the loosest version of a script then
our director alex timbers saw for the
first time in new york at ucb one a
one-off and then we opened on the cherry
at cherry lane like the next day or two
days later or something oh my god and
then we ran into cherry lane for like 24
25 shows and over three or four weeks
and we fat we kept tweaking it as we
went there and then we toured it five
nights in dc five nights in boston five
nights in new york five nights in la
and
there we tweaked it further we kept
rewriting it and then we had three weeks
of rehearsal in new york and then we
brought it to broadway and even on
broadway we were rewriting and writing
we basically were improvising the third
act not every night entirely but we were
improvising huge chunks of it and as we
found it we would keep it and so like
the whole third act basically comes out
of us improvising every night on
broadway oh my god that's brave
that would be that would scare the [ __ ]
out of me i uh so it was none of it was
i mean it was we knew where it had to go
like we knew it was gonna go yeah crazy
tuna like
sandwich
dance sequence we had a structure of it
but the dialogue but even inside the
dialogue then would affect story-wise
you know that gill is dating lisa the
raccoon
and sure lisa's coming between george
and gil all that stuff was just every
night kind of improvising and trying
different things knowing like let's try
tonight to lean into this
breakup between gil and this raccoon or
whatever and our stage manager artie
gaffin who just who passed away a year
ago um
this week and and i i toast put it on
instagram he gave
his estate gave a hundred grand to
broadway cares and he's a really amazing
amazing man
but he would write up the artist's rep
the the stage manager report which was a
thing on broadway at least
he did i assume but normally it's
uneventful it's like tonight justin long
his mic we lost his mic on the third
line of you know the second act and
it was fixed artie wrote these really
beautiful long incredibly descriptive
pieces about each night on broadway he
would basically
gill mused about release of the raccoon
tonight and their possible love affair
and we would read that and then the next
day we would lean in oh my god it was
really oh wow what an important piece of
play then i'm sorry yeah yeah he he he i
one day we'll publish them all because
they're really amazing but but anyway it
was we fixed one thing every night you
know we
just keep plugging away and we had we
knew we had the jokes um and we knew we
had each other
and uh
that was must have really i know you
guys were buddies before but that must
have been an intense bonding incredibly
bonding it's you know you've done
obviously theater it's incredibly
bonding experience but when you're just
yeah but six months like that like a
high wire act like that was just yeah
you listening to it yeah it was it was
the most fun thing and we keep finding
things to do together but it as for a
friendship it's it's on it was
undeniably
important to us as friendship and our
lesson out of that was like what's the
most fun thing to do what's the most
interesting thing that we can do and to
just do that and not worry too much
about like what feels like the right
move career-wise or what's the
you know just like what it seems fun
does that seem fun life could be a dream
[Music]
what do you want to do next i know i i
recently saw adult
beginners that's why it's also nice it's
funny like you're so good in that movie
that i
i am associating you somewhat with your
with your character of being a little
you know
untethered and lost and you know you're
dealing with uh these family things uh i
know that's not you yeah but yeah
you're
you're creating it do you want to do
more work yeah i would love to i mean
the world feels so [ __ ] crazy right
now it's like how do we i don't know
what acting is or sets our
i love acting and i would like to do it
i i
you know as you well know it's like the
life of an actor
is a really um
can feel really powerless and
like even when you are
getting the opportunity to act a lot
you're not necessarily getting the
opportunity to
say what you want to say or
or like
you know so i i think like creating the
shows that i've created has been an
attempt to just regain control um power
power
um so yeah right now um we're working on
a spin-off of big mouth called human
resources which um when you get to the
end of season two
um you'll see there's an episode where
you go to the workplace of the monsters
and the creatures like the hormone
monsters and the shame wizard shame
wizards and all that stuff like
so we're working on a spin-off right now
um that that will come out after season
five of big so it's not going to come
out for a while but we're
so i've been working on that with the
similar the same partners and team as
big mouth and some new folks um
and i've started a production
company uh that i'm starting to write
and really help other people make stuff
um that's great so i love doing all of
it you're so good on curb last season
the curb
to me the performances on that are split
into two different camps the people who
look like they're
trying to be funny and do stuff yeah you
know and um yeah
you know what i mean and you fell into
the other category which i much prefer
which is
you just you know stuck to the intention
of the character you weren't looking for
the joke was that you just knowing where
to be in the scenes or did they direct
you to do that that's very nice of you
to say i got very lucky that they gave
me a bit that was like a classic curb
bit like you know it's like it's a mater
d
and larry feels like he's being sat in
the ugly ugly section it's like such a
curb it's such a classic curb like
premise yes um yeah and jeff shafer who
who writes and directs a lot of the show
with larry
created the league and um
and so i had worked with jeff
extensively so he knew exactly kind of
my wheelhouse and
larry actually played ruxin in the
future on the league so i had actually
had the opportunity to work with larry a
little bit
so i was a little less intimidated than
i normally
which if i hadn't had that experience of
working with larry david i think i would
have been much more freaked out by it
and i knew him a little socially and
that that i could do it and he's the
funny thing with larry is you know i
think everybody's like oh he's this
sour he's who he's never having fun
yeah but he's
i find him to be a very sweet guy and
very that's what i've heard very easy
and very kind of like a good laugher
he's a great laugher which you're just
like oh i i'm
making larry david laugh and i'm so and
he really can put you at ease in a way
that other people like him who you think
are going to be super nice are not
always and
um in fact he cracks up doesn't he laugh
like dirt doesn't he break a lot during
he can see him sort of like well you
know he's uh and that's part of the
that's part of it
part of the character's part of the joy
of the show and part of similar yeah
with oh hello which is you know people
want to see you having fun and you watch
curbing you see him having fun with his
friends you know and like that's
part of the
the chemistry and the magic of that show
is is that so
um yeah yeah that was that's it was i
loved seeing you on it uh um all right
these are quick these are quick
lightning round because i know you gotta
go what is your most commonly used emoji
would you say
oh
oh
oh [ __ ]
um let me look like a go-to to punctuate
like
i'm trying to get better at using um
at using like the thumbs uppy stuff
um but i don't i don't get to use it
very much let me see
you mean the different versions of the
hand like the kind of hawaiian thing you
know like the thumbs up or like the
little part or whatever uh the number
one is um i like prayer hands
i think i do a lot of prayer hands
i do that a lot too i do like that in
the context of like thank you
uh if you could be a professional
athlete i think i know this but what
sport would you play oh i think it would
be basketball now i would i've fell back
in love with basketball in in the last
couple years i did a this movie uncle
drew and i got to play with a bunch of
those guys
and that was great
that was so [ __ ] fun
um that's right you played without that
i mean lebron what was it
kyrie and
tyree and shaq and and reggie miller and
it was and it was the most fun it was
like i was again that was a project i
took after oh hello where i was like i
don't know i don't care if this movie's
good or bad i want to go play basketball
with these guys and and it was super fun
and and i had a great time getting them
so basketball for sure are the knicks
your team the knicks are the knicks were
my team
what about for you or was it celtic yeah
no the knicks because we were close we
were yeah you know it was like celtics
were kids that were more further and
further upstairs yeah
i was and i was at a bunch of those
games i was at like i was at the a bunch
of the games in the last dance like
those like those like the this is no
kidding yeah this i was at the game when
spike lee and and reggie miller got into
it no [ __ ] the yeah the choke thing and
i was at the game when the knicks
finally beat the bulls um
in the playoffs um yeah and i actually
left that game early because i had to go
to a synagogue i had to go to rehearsal
for a synagogue production of oklahoma
that's how committed i have been to
um oh my god but that was our you know
that was a fun era of the knicks but now
i don't i don't
i know it's hard to hard to root for the
knicks um yeah but i moved for honestly
i root for good games i really like me
time that's all i care about and i kind
of
i kind of root for lebron i kind of like
i can't stop rooting oh yeah lebron uh
if you could have one snack food for the
rest of your life oh that's a tough one
because i'm a i'm a snack fella um
uh i like a salt and vinnie salt and
vinegar potato chip
uh
yeah
i like uh i mean a take five candy bar
uh
oh interesting it's a major candy bar
for me i like a
really a sour
take five best candy bar in the market
never quite broke through but the best
candy bar no it's like a grand avenue
yeah it's it's uh
it's the take five five ingredients are
chocolate caramel peanuts peanut butter
and the secret weapon is the pretzel
uh oh i take it out yeah it's the best
candy bar i think reese's has taken it
over and rebranded as like the reese's
take five it's the best candy bar in the
game right now
oh okay if it's the reese's one i've had
i mean i love a simple chocolate covered
pretzel i love um uh-huh so i'm i'm a
little snack i'm a little snack baby i'm
i'm
have you
have you been smoking marijuana
we can cut it out
i
i mean a little bit but it has not been
a major
like
it's not been a major element of my
staple it's it's too it's
like pod for me
is something that i use not to calm me
down it's a something to spark creative
energy
uh huh do you write on it ever i will
use it at points in the creative process
yeah yeah yeah you know sometimes it's
like i'm gonna go for a hike and think
about this thing and i'll you know
people get upset with me for this one uh
my brother always teases me about it
what is your favorite movie of all time
oh
i mean for a long time it was the
producers the original the the mel
brooks movie um his first movie um which
i came to a little after like blazing
saddles and
and history of the world and young
frankenstein but then i found the
producers and it was sort of my
kind of my favorite movie um
did you see it on broad did you see no i
never well the first my first acting job
one of my first acting jobs was i told
larry this was
um i was an extra uh on a day of curb
your enthusiasm when larry was playing
max bialystock on broadway
when it was david schwimmer as leo bloom
and and you know so i was
an extra
watching larry david in curb your
enthusiasm do
um
the producers it was kind of
the amazing confluence and i stayed up
were you in the rehearsal no no no it
was like an audience member i was just
literally sitting in the audience in the
st james theater and oh my god i did the
morning and by the afternoon the extras
i was with were talking about the the
lack of quality of the bagels at craft
service and i and i took off i was like
i can't i just can't do this like i
can't did you tell him that i did yeah i
told him the whole thing
what did he he was like oh great great
um but uh yeah no i never honestly i
never saw the producers on broadway i
never watched the movie because i i
weirdly i didn't want to ruin the movie
so so important to me that i didn't but
the other movie i watched so growing up
as a little kid a lot was top secret i
don't know if you've seen top secret oh
yeah yeah go back and watch that it's
it's the like the forgotten zucker
brothers movie zucker brothers
after airplane and before
uh
yeah and it's it came out the same
weekend as like
three huge movies and so it was a
failure but it's
it's young handsome val kilmer it's like
it's um we it's um real genius era val
kilmer it's super and it's a it's a bit
every three seconds literally god you
know i don't think i've seen that since
i was a kid watching go watch go watch
top secret again val kilmer is so
[ __ ] funny the movie is has it
literally a visual bit every three
seconds um oh wow okay i'm looking at
peter cushing wow omar sharif yeah it's
it's it's worth a watch it's worth a
watch if you have it was he hands yeah
um uh
okay i will i i
you know people that's similar to like
well i'm surprised that you could do
that val kilmer and mcgruber people were
like wow i can't believe he's so but he
started doing that oh my god the
funniest if you ever have will forte i
have will forte oh you know will's
coming on yeah yeah talking about kilmer
who their their they became very close
to making mcgruber
um they've lived together yes yes yeah
yeah talk to talk to will about it
okay okay
um if you had to live somewhere else
where would it be
well i think we're all asking ourselves
that question right now yeah yeah
yeah state of our country um yeah i mean
i love my family uh obviously i always i
want to be closer to home but i
i went um the end of this year uh last
year to 19 2019 uh i was doing a
stand-up tour and went to australia and
new zealand uh in australia we were
there for all the fires so
um oh god
all right but then we went to new
zealand to i did a show in auckland and
we were only there for like three or
four days but i would
probably go back there
um yeah have you been there have you
spent time no i'm dying to go i'm dying
that's a place that's on my list it's
kind of magical literally magical but
and the people seem really cool and they
just
they seem to have a lot of their
priorities in order and
i really loved it um you know it's a
tiny little island but i think like all
the tech bro billionaires bought their
like apocalypse houses there so they had
to like now i feel like new zealand like
kind of shut their borders a little bit
so like oh really that's the same if you
have dinner with three people dead or
alive when you've never met who would it
be
uh [ __ ] i should know this
um
it's it's not a great lightning round
question and we can come back to it yeah
come back to it let me think okay uh
who's your favorite muppet i don't think
much about the muppets but i'm thinking
about i'm thinking about gonzo right now
uh-huh yeah
yeah
not a kermit guy uh
miss piggy's got a lot of personality
she seems like a lot
um
gonzo tries really hard it's it's it's
uh it's funny in the tron yeah i love
that um uh i think raw from muppet
babies i like as well oh yeah oh yeah
uh a real entertainer i just like a
solid showman um if you had to be one
age for the rest of your life what would
you pick physically
knowing what you know now you have your
brain you just get to have this body oh
you get to have this [ __ ] physically
yeah i mean i i think i it would be hard
to disagree with being like
like 19.
um but i don't i have to say like i like
i'm 42
um
i like
where i am in life like i like you know
right this age at least like my body
hasn't broken down um
and i but i've learned so much like in
my 20s and even in my 30s i felt like i
was like slowly just figuring out like
life in so many ways that i'm like i
kind of like where i am right now
i know it's true what they say the youth
is wasted on yeah on the young uh i know
i it's true my body isn't broken down
but i'm seeing
just enough cracks in it to appreciate
and and to be able to kind of like um
uh i can see what's on the horizon yeah
right i'm getting like little tiny taste
of what oh yeah you know for a couple
years my shoulder was [ __ ] up and i
was like oh this is what this is what
this is what the future holds and it
sucks yeah
um if you uh
now i'm picturing you guys doing
oh hello but you know when you're
actually that age you're funny um if you
could be reincarnated as a non-human
animal uh what would you pick
an animal that you really identify with
oh
this is terrible but i'm i would like to
be i wouldn't mind being a lion
no no somebody else just said that uh no
great you sleep a lot you're kind of
like leave you alone um i mean i think
raccoons are very funny
i think raccoons are very funny animals
they they really we have a ton of them
here and my brother's girlfriend's
always calling for me to see that
because the motion sensor will go on yes
and he's over it he's like who cares
they're a bunch of he thinks they're a
little like grubby yeah they feed they
are and but they have these little hands
it's their hands their hands yes i can
get stuck in a uh raccoon like youtube
video like oh sure deep i can go deep on
that yeah yeah uh would you rather be
called unattractive or unfunny that's a
great one
i think unattractive although
if i really honestly dug in deep i'm
like i could i would probably
i could go really could go either way on
that one because i'm right boy i would
i've made my entire existence on being
think people like my my well-being has
been built on being funny but like
ultimately i still just want to be
attractive you know right
well
we're those kids we're the
kids
yeah um dogs are cats dogs
do you have any uh no growing up i had
dogs i did a there was i had like a long
stand up at my old act about dogs and
cats and and um and i i grew i've now
grown to appreciate people who like cats
and through their eyes but i don't like
cats at all i'm allergic to cats so it's
like uh so am i yeah i'm just moving my
computer's about to die um
you know what we're almost done
okay um sorry nick that's fine sorry
really quick uh which golden girl do you
most identify with dorothy blanche rose
or sophia um i think uh sophia i thought
was always the funniest she always made
me laugh yeah
sassy um
thank you for doing this this was my
pleasure thanks for having me selfishly
love to see yeah it's great to see you
man okay hopefully i'll see you soon
thank you for your time my pleasure
talking about all right take care
everybody
so that happened
that was my
voice yeah that was my impression of
like a big mouth character voice just
like a generic big mouth character
that's pretty good yeah kind of like
guys oh my god your face is so handsome
when you do that really handsome you
just like make your tongue big it's not
this
yes
he does i gotta tell you he is um
i've you know how much i value
vocal gifts like that i mean i just
think he's such a virtuoso
i think he's so gifted at those voices
he is well you are too thank you you
guys line up a lot as people i would say
yeah i think that's when we get along
only a couple days
separated my age one day three days i
believe oh really yeah oh sorry you
don't seem three days older no i think
myself as being maybe three years
younger he always seemed to have
uh like a real maturity to him
you know like a like a grubby toss yeah
he has had
gravitas he has always yeah even when um
we've known him for years when did we
see him at i was trying to remember when
we saw him at south by southwest perform
you wear that show right now uh yeah
i've he used to live
in my neighborhood in la our
neighborhood i always noticed that he
treated everyone equally and he didn't
treat people with more status yeah in a
better way which it's surprisingly rare
yeah i know you don't and i'm uh like an
expert i think you're right at judging
this because i've
been in the company of people with
status
a lot
and i don't have status myself so you
have some status no i don't i mean i i'm
a person i'm like uh you know yeah
you're i don't know i'm put status in a
business
so i uh so i became very good at
differentiating yeah the way people
treat people you're right yeah and nick
and he and i i always noticed that about
him that he
was uh equally
friendly
with everybody regardless he's great
yeah you really like him you're a really
big fan yeah i always have been a big
guy i know i i just am i but i think
like you're an extra big fan but after
the interview you realize you really you
often don't really want to know how it
goes that much it's like generally
you're like how'd it go obviously but
but
you wanted to know you were very curious
about it and
were very you and you're also not a
gushy person i've heard really because
it's you know
he's the combination for me i think he
is both very very funny and talented
and
very very
nice and a good person well and what's
the other thing you were saying about
him like he doesn't feel the need to
show a lot of funny people feel that
especially on a podcast you they'll
begin performing yeah they'll do a
version of their material i find myself
doing that yeah like i you want to
present you and there are
you know different degrees of that with
i think with the people that we talked
to on the show and i would say nick is
um
very uh he's on the on the the end of
the spectrum that is not at all not that
spectrum
no no no no not that's why but on this
is the spectrum of like trying like how
hard somebody's trying so again you're
three days apart you're both good at
impressions you
um are both from
the same general area he's from
westchester you're from fairfield's it's
like half an hour away
um so
you have a lot and we have similar
familiality you have a lot in common
yeah close family
uh you both as did i hit puberty very
late and you guys talked about that yeah
and that time and it when you were
talking about that it reminded me of
that no just that time in general how
everyone is insecure for different
reasons and you brought up maggie you're
like i shouldn't say this but i'm gonna
say it where she developed
uh before other girls developed
and at the time you know we're
11 12 year old boys yeah
we think that's amazing oh how lucky are
you yeah i like i that was so exciting
when girls developed
and we just assume that that's a good
thing for them whether there was a girl
i don't want to say her name but we had
that girl in like six
it was like fifth or sixth grade who
developed and
and i for years always assumed even even
into adulthood i always thought like she
must have loved that she must have loved
it probably a nightmare
i bet and that's why i think you'd
really love big mouth because they i've
seen a little bit of yeah funny it's
funny but it's also like that it's
really insightful it's very
uh i can't believe i'm saying this but
i've it's made me think about uh
things in my own
uh adolescence and like other people's
it's made me more kind of sensitive to
other people's experiences i didn't get
picked on a lot in school
generally but i remember one time i did
there was like a handful of times that i
really stick out my memory of getting
picked on and feeling embarrassed you
know getting like teased
i was in eighth grade in orchestra
play the cello and the bass player
won't say his name but he was like the
star athlete you know
and this guy had
gone through puberty and like you know
kindergarten he was one of those guys he
was like on his knuckles he was like a
fully developed man by this point and i
an eighth grader was like a couple years
away from approaching puberty
and he you looked very never forget you
look like a nymph very young and this
guy this ape
um
made fun of me for not having hair on my
legs and i was so embarrassed that for
the rest of the year i didn't wear
shorts i was like afraid to wear shorts
so i wore long pants every day no matter
how hot it got isn't that crazy it's
crazy but at the time it's like
who cares about her i know but but
you're so insecure and sensitive during
that time yeah of course i remember it i
i i got picked on by but it wasn't
picked on i looking back this guy used
to call me um i mean some kids did pick
on me but this one kid who i think was
really nice brian french we talked about
him on the show handsome guy handsome
yeah you remember brian was like he was
like man handsome as a sixth grader
again i'm not sure if we're allowed to
say that uh i'm not saying it as an
adult i'm saying it my perspective of
him as a fellow sixth grader so
well yeah it's still dicey but as a
sixth grader i remember thinking brian
is like a chiseled handsome man yeah
he's like tom brady yes
tom brady when he's not throwing a fit
by the way that was a real turn off time
tom brady's been throwing like you you
just noticed no i know throwing fits for
20 years i know i know but it was a real
turn off when he did it i was like
yelling at his new teammates it's like
dude
i know you're tom brady and like you're
43 you're an elder statesman but like
this older statesman
but this is a new team for you you know
like stop
he's like screaming at us but anyway but
anyway brian french used to call me um
well he called me curious george for a
while i can see that
yeah but that's mean for yeah but see
like to me i thought it like because i
knew what that illustration looked like
and i liked curious george up until then
but it was like a little monkey i mean
and yeah and he didn't mean your
personality no no he's like a little
like
yeah maybe he's part of the alert well i
was a little bit like that too maybe he
meant that but then he also started
going you're still a little bit like
yeah i i'm not offended by now but at
the time you know you're so aware of
like i was i was so aware of like what i
looked like and i'm so underdeveloped
and and uh he'd call me paul simon was i
like a little bulk i looked like paul's
i mean i'd look like i think it's cool
to look like paul now i do well not now
with this like best surgery but like not
now there's
there are few people cooler than paul
simon right but i don't think he was
taking that into account i think he
meant purely physically and it was like
oh this guy who's like physically really
yeah it's hurtful it was hurtful i
remember being so desperate to get uh
pubes desperately too because i was such
a late bloomer and i remember
uh this might be tmi but i remember
i finally got my one
like gross long underarm hair under my
right armpit in my right armpit
and two
long disgusting hairs on my left in my
left armpit i remember though i don't
remember those hands and the two one
combination lasted god it seems like
months it was probably wrong i remember
it was probably like four days but it
seemed like an eternity and then and
then one day it was just like
yeah
and now
i would i wouldn't mind having a little
less body hair yes little less nose hair
a little lighter
i know it's really gone in reverse uh it
really has and how much you want those
things and it's like yeah but i i also
had a thing of like i wanted to hold on
to my
childhood for a while i had a real like
peter pan complex i think and like in it
i wanted my i didn't i wanted my youth
to like we talked about how we the last
day right before you didn't you didn't
uh like fetishize
body hair you know weirdly no am i
playing baseball and seeing kids who are
cut off shirts and i'd i'd like peek
under their arm and see that if a lot of
under armour i'd be
i would always be a little freaked i
didn't mind being hairless for a while
i uh in fact when i started getting
those
you're right i remember a funny sound
bite
i was like a little uh subterranean
like you're looking f'd after like a
mole like a baby uh marsupial but i i
didn't mind but i do what freaked me out
was um
was when it did start growing in like
stuff started happening but i still
looked like a little boy i still had
like little boy
you know and then you're right then like
there'd be like a few hairs here and
there and be like oh my god what is
happening it was like the fly it's like
yeah
it was a little scary but exciting i was
more excited than scared because i
wanted it so badly well then once it
starts happening you're like okay now i
just i want it to
happen but it happens in such like fits
and spurts that it's like
fix and spurt it really is a crazy time
i can't believe everyone goes through
that i know it's crazy and again like
the show that's why the show is so great
it captures the the insanity of it and
and also forget the like i mean we can't
really so much talk about the there's a
like a horny monster in the
in the show and and they handle that
really well too because it really is
like this thing that's like control this
new presence that's like yeah i want you
to do that and that's like compelling
you to
make really bad
you know yeah decisions and so in some
cases it continues
right into adulthood um i like his
his uh fix one thing every day mantra do
you remember him talking about that
mm-hmm
and uh and he learned that lesson from
austin pendleton yeah who's yeah who's
great great actor um but that's i think
that's a really smart approach because i
think so often
i know i get overwhelmed by all the
stuff i want to change and all the you
and you get in a rut because you're like
oh i can't it piles up it piles up and
you feel kind of um suffocated by all
the things you want to do differently
but if you just do one thing a day and
change one thing and prove one thing a
day
it's that it's the babies it's like what
about bob the baby step baby mentality
but i think that's really an effective
approach to life keep stepping bob
baby steps out the door baby steps into
the elevator i'm in the elevator
i'm sailing i had that moment the other
day because cat
my friend kat staying at the cabins with
her family and she she had reference but
she was like it's like what about bob
here it is it is it's like winnipesaukee
yeah i'm sailing
keep sailing bob uh i very much agree
with his sultan sultan vinnie he says
selling vinegar chips uh couldn't agree
more i like his passion for snacks he
got really excited about that that was
an asa gonzalez as well they have that
in common yes they uh
yeah they do have that in common uh but
the take five candy bar i haven't heard
that and oh my god that a take five
candy bar is something i've never had
but it's something i've been aware of i
know my entire life it's like i always
see it it's in my mind it's always
especially as a kid when you're picking
candy out it's like an obvious no i know
the first one you discard it's like a
score yes or like a hundred grand yeah
yeah and it's like old school it was
funny like cat's kids said um she had
brought me a gift basket and i was like
and i
rejected it i didn't want it because i
didn't want it to be like this
transactional thing like oh you're
letting me stay at my place and like i
cat's a friend of mine and i didn't want
her to feel that way and i get very
uncomfortable receiving gifts and stuff
so i said no no and so the kids took it
and they were like yay gift bag and gift
basket and um they started tearing into
it and i asked the oldest one margie how
how i was like what did you think of the
bat and she goes yeah there's a lot of
old she's 12. a lot of old people
candies and i i was like and i knew what
she meant but i was like oh like what
and she was like hmm like pistachio
brittle
i love possession i know i know well
there you go
full circle we're becoming old that's
the first thing but now i really want to
try to take five bar yeah yeah because i
trust him i know right in general yeah
he seems like well-versed yeah not just
snacks but johnny he says like watch
this i mean he talked about top secret
that movie yeah i want to see that too i
know well you're a
big fan big fan yeah you were a big fan
going in and now i feel like it's just a
bigger fan
yeah does that ever happen on the show
where like you're a fan of somebody's
going in and then afterwards you're like
oh maybe a little less
uh it has happened really yeah but not
often
i feel like getting to know people in
general is
you end up seeing
i mean this is a very optimistic thing
for me to say but i i think i end up
seeing
more good things than bad things when
you hear yeah from someone for an hour i
think so too and even the things that
are maybe like bother you about somebody
or you think are you know less
attractive or desirable qualities
they i think getting to know them a bit
explains where those come from and it
humanizes them and yes so you have
compassion for those things exactly um
let's read a letter okay i sent it to
you i've emailed it to you cool did you
get it uh i
probably did and here it is that i did
um oh by the way yeah oh okay so it's
the it's i we've been getting a lot of
great i haven't read all of them yet but
a lot of great ed letters and i just saw
your subject by the show ed about the
show ad yes sorry
um
so i want to thank everyone too who
wrote in about that it's been making me
feel really nice i posted some
fun stuff on instagram about that uh
okay this is from some bts yeah bts for
a tbt or maybe it was fba what's the
flashback fbf
um or maybe mcm what's that man crush
monday
um
do you feel old when don't you feel old
too when people are like at lmao and
like use things like that like acro like
uh
rof i i've learned so many of those late
you know writing lol ir i never got on
board with that iron and that was like
the the og i never got on board that's
how people expressed uh laughing when
when this like internet age started lol
wasn't that the first and it always
bothered me it did me too and and you
know what bothered me even more when
people started saying lol oh boy that's
tough yep
i don't want to judge people because i
love people i like say that really
well well you should get some new
friends
yeah yeah lol
no no people i really like say that my
friend katya says that i think lol
ironically
no
anyways
okay
here we go kim
bohannon
kimbo let's just call it kimbo kim
subject ed and stuff
hello guys just a quick note to say i
was one of those i was one of those huge
fans of ed when it was on tv ah see like
people and i shouldn't have said on that
episode with tom like no one saw it and
like
i cannot believe it's been close to 20
years ago yeah
yeah i know by the way the show may not
be streaming but recently here in vegas
at least it reared from episode one as a
marathon it was so great to watch again
oh that's cool love that show and the
entire cast thank you for the interview
with tom whose smile brightens every
room that is an understatement
that that's true as well as my day
whenever i see him online on stage or on
screen yeah tom is
he'll brighten a screen
your podcast has been so enjoyable thank
you kim i've listened from day one aye
and find justin's genuine nature to be a
big part of the show's charm you hear
that
ugh you're so charming
thanks kim the covid check-ins were
entertaining and informative and i can't
thank you enough for bringing dr dave to
our homes so we could hear first-hand
accounts and perspectives from the
medical field oh
dr dave we like dr dave
and since life is short i feel compelled
to tell you i'm 46 and back to school
cool
adding the necessary sciences to my
original broadcast communications degree
so i can apply to the pa program and
enjoy the last third of my life actively
participating in patient care
that's great uh last third though i mean
46 that's the last no one knows no one
knows
i've spent the last decade in medical
sales and i've always wished i could do
more so i made a plan and she'd be in my
new role by the young age of 50. and she
does a one of those faces smiling but
with the hands up uh and she says
favorite emoji
you know that like yay it's a
kind of like that jonah you know that
jonah gif of from him from get him to
the greek where he's like ah he's so
excited he's like waving his palms and
justin you and christian really get my
tuesdays off to a great start thank you
for all you do making us laugh and
spreading positivity have a great week
kim kimbo oh that's fine she calls
herself kimba weird las vegas nevada p.s
from jacob yeah oh great jacob age eight
i answered kid uh or just her friend
right your old friend uh would you
rather for the rest of your life have
olives at each tip of all your fingers
or lizard feet that's a great question
jacob lizard feet or olives at the tip
like yeah you remember we used to do
that put olives on oh but not like your
fingers aren't olives
my first question what's yours what can
you eat them off right yeah and then
replace them
well you get sick of them because you
probably i'm guessing jacob doesn't
speculate but you probably have to have
them on all the time if you have to have
them on all the time i would definitely
pick your favorite yeah me too in fact
having little tv would be kind of cool
it would be like a it would be a party
trick yeah and you know if you had like
you know the
nerd alert coming up uh the basilisk
lizard jacob do you know about the
basilisk lizard that's the uh they call
the jesus lizard which i know might be
offensive to some people but i didn't
name it it's the lizard that runs on
water i've seen that yeah they can run
on water and they do incredible those
are the
feet you want uh yeah i would take those
if i got to pick from any lizard funny
picturing you running on water now i did
yeah haircut i tried to do that on this
a character i played tried to do that in
a movie oh yeah where i had similar hair
oh we didn't talk about the hair who
cares it's not it's a podcast yeah
justin has a crazy haircut i have a
mullet basically but i played a
character with a mullet in a movie
called sasquatch gang and i had to write
there was a joke where i said i'm like
he's a real like defiant uh
strong-willed idiot and he said uh he
thought he could run on water too so we
had to shoot god i'll never forget that
was i'll never forget that because it
was we shot uh it was cold it was cold
out and we shot on the clackamas river
which is really cold and that and and uh
they have a medic standing by with a
thermal blanky blanket
uh of course we only did one take and
then that stunt guy did like five takes
and he was like yeah it's not bad and i
was like
i can't catch up with this like thermal
blanket and a team of medics around me
um anyway i would definitely yeah jacob
good question but i would have the
lizard feet for sure even though i i
love olives and and now that's the main
the main problem with having the owl
fingers
is just uh it would make it
difficult to do anything function to
grab pick things up uh people would
constantly be looking at your hands yeah
yeah the feet you can cover up easily
what would you prefer green olives or
black olives you had to have black why i
just like the taste better and you
wouldn't get to eat them oh that's right
they'd be stuck out then
tempted to eat my fingers do you just
poke out the pimento
yeah you have to right i guess so or
your finger would be jammed in there
with the pimento and leaking around it'd
be gross too and like
and it's a pretty strong scent yeah it
is not with black olives though lesser
but yeah much less
yeah so but i have a question if if
would they come off as you're doing
things like would they be permanently
stuck on there if they're permanently
stuck on then
uh regardless i i would choose yeah
okay thank you jacob and
uh way to spell oh he's supposed to be c
minus i think you know i don't know how
to spell my middle name the proper
spelling are you serious i'm dead
serious it's a j it's jacob okay it's k
yeah it's j-a-k-o-b i can't believe you
don't know i always
now i remember that you're right weird i
know how could you forget because
jacob the c is so much more common and i
can never remember if it's
i know i guess now that i said it's
uncommon and
i don't know
you never forget how to spell the other
two parts of your name right no no
but uh there have been times where i've
messed it up it's really embarrassing uh
kimberly thank you kim kimbo
uh have fun out there in las vegas
uh and uh good luck with your new
pursuit our our mom did yeah a similar
thing when she was in her 40s same age
she went back to school got her masters
and became a uh teacher and you know
it's always so nice now too she's since
retired but it's so nice to run into
it also makes you feel speaking feeling
old it makes me feel really old when
like a huge like an adult with like a
receding hairline and like you know
they're like hey uh i had your mom in
school i know a teacher and because
knowing how late she got into it
relatively
uh and she taught what she taught uh
great middle school yeah and they
sometimes they look
about the same age as you oh yeah thanks
to the hormones but they probably like
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah they probably don't think [ __ ] [ __ ]
is that big of a deal right thank you to
kimbo that was a great letter and thanks
for the
son for the would you rather yeah thanks
jacob and we wish you lots of luck in
your
new career and um thanks again to your
favorite my favorite nick kroll
yeah and also i got to mention that um i
i think we did on the show but it bears
repeating that um when i asked him to do
that charity thing that we were doing
with with uh
churches the great band churches we um
he didn't hesitate he texted back right
when do you need it there was no like
some of the people that were also kind
enough to do the show was like you know
and this is how i would be you know
trying to figure out the hemming hauling
a little bit nick said yes and and he's
a good dude good dude so um and we
appreciate him being on the show and if
you guys want to write in our email
address is life is short at wondery.com
and we will speak to you all
next week thanks for listening
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long and it's co-hosted and produced by
you christian long as well as megan
monaco she produces it not co-hosted and
senior producer is michelle miesh lans
audio engineer is sergio enriquez with
two fellows by the names of
marshall louis and hernan lopez by the
company wondering
[Music]
you know what's
that's a good question isn't it who
do men have larger nipples than women in
general that's how big they are
like just like physiologically who has
smaller nipples
or do they or do they have the same it
doesn't it depends on the person
i know but as a rule i don't think like
overall nipples are bigger than women
female nipples
well like i'm saying like overall how
men overall are taller than women yes
that's true generally and heavier
heavier and all that yeah so
would they have bigger nipples over like
generally probably just because they're
bigger
that's a good question that's a good
question i i'm trying to i've never seen
really big nipples on a man oh i have
i've seen big meaties like pepperonis
you have yeah way
you